uh cyber Punk man the uh what you call
it the Phantom Liberty expansion is out
with a shout out to CD project red uh
providing IP codes for the latest
experien so we can take a look and see
what's going on just want to quickly
breakdown for those who've been living
under a rock as far as what feature set
has been offered obviously it's been the
update 2.0 and the expansion and the
update 2.0 which was a free update so
redesigned skill trees and perks
revamped cyberware and new capacity
system vehicle combat and car chases
combat AI improvements new police system
UI and ux improvements loot item and
crafting changes new radio stations
including Community radio station growl
FM and then obviously we got the Phantom
Liberty that paid expansion we got our
man Idris Ela AKA Stringer Bell for
those who know why doing his thing and
uh dog Town dangerous new District in
the game uh brand new storyline and
characters new Quest Quest gigs boss
fights and more vehicle missions and
airdrops endless Dynamic events all New
Relic Relic skill tree and abilities 100
plus new items weapons cyberware cars
and fashion vehicle missile launchers
and the level crap increase to 60 so
this thing has gone out getting you know
fairly positive reviews from what I'm
seeing most of it and I know we've
played a bit but uh I don't want to do
the impression I do want to take it a
different direction which is kind of
like obviously we know the history of
cyber Punk we've all seen this this is a
game you know at
launch the multiple consoles past
generation current generation
performance let's be honest pretty much
dragged um to the point that um remember
this was a game that was delisted at one
point from the uh Playstation store so
with everything that's going on now and
obviously this is um uh an update as
well as nextg only and stuff like like
that for those who played it whatever
your pressions are but is this the
Redemption Arc for cyber Punk so let's
start with Lord addict what are what are
your thoughts bear I think it is I think
you know they went back and they've done
enough
now the argument on should they be
forgiven for releasing the game in the
state it was that's a different argument
but I feel like they did go back and fix
the condition of their game
at least now if you guys still are on
this I ain't going to buy it because I
don't feel comfortable supporting the
type of practices that they did you know
releasing the game that was in that kind
of condition I I could feel that but as
far as like this DLC the patch 2.0 I do
feel like if cyberp Punk would have came
out in this condition at launch then we
could really give them 100% props but I
can never really give them 100% of that
it's like look you fix something that
should have been fixed from day one
that's cool the game is a solid
experience and I'd recommend you guys go
play it uh but for me as myself I'm
still I'm still let half and half on
like recommending someone to because I
my thing is
like even though they went back and
fixed it it's like do me personally it's
like Lord addict cosign telling people
to buy it when it's at that point where
it's like is does that reward bad
behavior or is that reward good behavior
because they fixed it or could you
consider that it should have been fixed
from the start so like you can't really
reward good behavior because it was
because it initiated and originated from
bad behavior I don't know uh but all I
know is cyber Punk is is pretty fun like
it's it's a good game so you've been
feeling it um because you haven't played
since you kind of stayed away from it
I'm assuming and then now with the
Phantom Liberty kind of going back oh I
haven't played it since week one oh wow
so you stayed away completely yeah I I
dropped it cuz it it it I had like some
some like gamebreaking issues but it I
didn't have as many issues as other
people but I did have some issues and I
just dropped it waiting for a patch and
then game came out another game came out
another game came out and then it just
completely forgot about it um you know
it it's a fun experience it is U you
know you could talk about the uh I think
more of the moral guide where it's like
do you support this considering they
released it in the state they did
especially like last gen I don't know
that's what for you guys to decide I
feel like Studios do deserve Second
Chances and but that's G to go from
person to person I feel that I feel that
and a quick question because when you
started uh Phantom Liberty they give you
the option to start immediately from
where the new DLC is or do brand new
with all the update point to you know
from the beginning and then let it
integrate naturally which way did you go
I went start brand brand new new I had
play the Basse game so it would make no
sense for me to be like yo let me let me
jump in there in that Liberty I fa that
fair enough fair enough Lord Sovereign
cyberpunk you know obviously we know the
history you know obviously we know where
they are right now seems somewhat
positive reviews on on Phantom Liberty
where you at with this whole thing is
has cyber Punk earned a Redemption Arc
for you yeah I think 100% it has um you
know regardless of how the state that
that game came out in the devs the
people that that work hard on that game
for years and years and years knew full
well that that game should not be coming
out and that decision was not theirs to
make right it was made by people above
them and they had to deal with the
Fallout of it they had to deal with all
the BS and people blaming them and
pointing a finger at them and it's just
it's not really the way it is but at the
end of the day everybody has their
bosses everybody has their masters and
they say it's got to come out it's got
to come out and so and they dealt with
the Fallout of that and then continue to
work on the game now what this is 3
years later it's the 2020 game that came
out and they're still you know this is
going to be it for it right and and the
fact that they went and and basically
redid everything um and then in addition
to Phantom Liberty being attached to it
I just
think you have to you have to it's a
certain point in time you have to say
okay going to give this game a chance
now um I bought the game day one every
intention of playing it I bought it on
PC actually I bought it on Console as
well I had and uh and then you know the
stuff started coming out and because of
how bad the the conversation around it
was I was like you know what let me let
me just not right now yeah I didn't want
to do I want to be clear too that um we
did get review access to this they did S
I said that I said that transparent from
The Joint to let UPN against Pro hold on
hold on we do got to interrupt real
quick shout out to one of the biggest
cyberpunk fans in the chat our brother F
zelli gaming brother we love you rest in
peace rest in peace to your to to your
to your dad and uh again we put the link
in the chat if anyone who wants to
support you know what I mean as far as
the the funeral and any Services I'll
put the link back up in there but that's
a good brother man and far is one of the
biggest cyber Punk fans like his whole
Channel like even when he had the the
intro on you saw he had that kind
Cho Vibe man and hopefully you know when
things settle down you get a chance to
to game and stuff but uh love you
brother good to see you up in here man
we know you know what you're going
through and we really we really want to
empathize and show our love and support
to you yeah continue so so um so yeah I
you know I haven't played a lot of it I
just I threw it on because I wanted to
see what these changes were and to
really see how really how it could you
know how it ran on this new pc that we
have um yeah again I I put the NZXT bus
NZXT with NZXT in that Jo player three
AMD Edition AMD you showing off your
build on that cyber Punk the way it was
supposed to be played the way adct
supposed to play it yeah absolutely this
is one of the games I bullied them on
yes bully
us you're playing this on PC damn it um
and it and it shows out it really shows
out it is so well optimized again every
every time I put in new game I turn off
all sort of FSR I turn it all all off
just to see what the PC can do and then
if it's you know if it's like hiccuping
and having some issues then I turn on
some of the you know sh of flex bring
bring down the the resolution or
whatever um but no at 4K with rate with
rate tracing I didn't turn on path
tracing I'm gonna I'm going to try that
to see if it buckles the computer that
path Trac but but full rate tracing at
its
highest I have it on ultra settings
running beautifully at 60 this game this
game is still an absolute
showpiece this game running on on a PC
of that caliber with all the new bells
and whistles all the optimizations they
made to that game it is really something
to
behold I'm sorry and it really I mean
it's a showpiece and the fact of the
matter is that everything that was wonky
about the game they went in and changed
and they redid and they say you know
what don't go in with your with your SPC
out character start a new game trust us
start a new game so I've only played a
couple of hours of it just to kind of
get the feel for it and uh yeah it's it
feels like it's going to be a special
experience obviously I was anticipating
this experience three years ago I'm
gonna figure out a time to play it but
um I don't know how it runs on a rag oh
but honestly okay you you'll talk about
that honestly though I kind of want to
I'm kind of being selfish I'm like I
don't want to play it on anything other
than the I'm going to be real with you
big boy yeah it's such a
showpiece that like don't get me wrong
I'm want to go and I'm I'mma do it but
um that I I I'll talk about when it's my
turn but I yeah but I I know where
you're going I know where you're going
but but that was it though I haven't
played that much of it just enough to
see that it yeah they they've really
done the work so I think they deserve
the credit man you think about like a no
man Sky they went in there and and they
they still to this day working on that
damn game um so you know they've had
like a a decade long may Copa yeah um so
to me when it comes to dev's going in
and fixing a game and knowing that the
way the state the game came out in
affected their reputation immensely and
it kind of not being their fault um I'm
always going to give the devs a benefit
of the doubt and this feels like it was
like obviously management realized what
it did to them yeah and and you know the
the devs are now getting the shine they
should have gotten instead of the ey
that they received M um so I'm happy for
them I would say go out and buy this
game and you can find it it it went up
in price when Phantom Liberty came out
right because you could have found it
for 20 bucks the base game anyway for
you know weeks prior to that and all of
a sudden it jumps back up in price but
it's it's still 100% worth it because I
there aren't too many games that look
like this at all so yeah go out and get
it if you if you waited now is the time
yeah no absolutely absolutely I hear
what you're saying Lloyd King when was
uh stayed away I remember during the you
know the height of the drama it was it
was everywhere every you know and you
were pretty staunch on that but um yeah
now that you Phantom Liberty is out you
know am man's is outside you know what
I'm saying
string one thing I I can say is you know
days in our time it was uh a bad game
shifts it shifts it's bad
forever this time now a game can ship
bad but turn good over a period of time
right looking at you Arcane get back to
redfall
um CD project red has been really good
at that you know if a game has problems
through patches through uh free patches
mind you they don't they don't charge
for the upgrade because these these
upgrades and stuff these DLCs now they
charge for this DLC which is a little
departure from what they did with the
The Witcher but I I think with the The
Witcher was more of a Mia Copa you know
for that this one they felt that they
had a good game and I think they was
pushed out by board to to reach
unexpected uh shipment goals and that
affected the overall um value of the
product because you know if it's a
diminished product going out it's going
to have a diminished value and I think
now it's it's at a higher value with the
the the Phantom uh DLC and ildis and you
being able to start the game uh with all
that in place uh from base yeah they did
a lot of quality of life things um and
if if you're part of that world they
gave you more yeah right when
unexpectedly that you didn't know that
you was going to get this more that's
not even the DLC part I'm just talking
about the free update 2.0 is fire on its
own absolutely the game starts to look
like what they Envision I hope it has
the no man Sky success because no man
sky was ridiculed at launch uh for not
fulfilling whatever goals and stuff that
they set forth but now you look at NORAD
sky and you're like wow this game went
so far because of the love and passion
behind the developers that are willing
to go back in there and to deliver on
that promise so I'm never going to say
to a publisher right now with the
unrealistic goals of the board is
forcing you to do things but you're
still willing to stay there in the mud
and get out a game that you can say that
you're proud of so my hats off to you
guys the game is phenomenal and keep
grinding you know uh Excellence speaks
for itself a lot of companies don't do
it a lot of company leaves a broken game
a broken game and I think you know more
companies should back their product and
try to uh drop at what they initially
expected because cyberpunk was supposed
to be the game of a generation facts
right so for it to fall short of those
off the expectations I mean and for them
to go back and work on it you just got
to take your hat off to them yeah I'll
jump in I mean yeah this is a definitely
feel like a full circle kind of kind of
Arc I remember saw E3 I think this was
I's First Media when we went solo we
went back solo and it was E3 I think
2019 maybe I can't remember yes it was
2019 I had log Net's F that was loget
first first big behind the scenes with
CD project red cyber Punk behind the
scenes showing for the first time then
me and you you interviewed me was me and
you asking me questions about the game
he was out there LA and we got that jint
remember that J yeah that did that did
good for us that did good for Lord did
great for us it's a Pity that that
wasn't the game yeah it's a Pity that it
was on the highest end of PC and it
wasn't representative of it was the best
vertical
slice but when I saw it I was just like
man this game has so much potential and
um yeah the kind of the King's Point to
me the game looks so phenomenal it's how
I expected all of Next Generation to
look to me they set the tone as far as
the graphic now that we know the story
we know what happened and it was
disastrous you know what I'm saying um
to me just way too many platforms let's
be honest past gen should have been cut
out and and and they you know probably
maybe try to chase the board biggest
issue facts when you trying to develop
for base PS4 Bas Xbox One and you had
the new and let's be honest this is they
launched right in that transition period
where there's not enough install base
for the thing and the board man say yo
we need that and you're pushing these
developers to make on this that's why
I'm so happy with Phantom Liberty the
decision to cut Pas gen was there it's
only next gen and King only
ssds if you coming in there with that
mechanical hard drive you can't play
that is a requirement for this joint and
the difference yeah the difference is
there you know one one thing I do want
to give them their um flowers is and a
lot of games are not doing this and CD
project I love yall for this is y' c y
cloud crossplay is the greatest feature
I want this in every game you know once
you set it up once you you connect to
the CD project red site or whatever it
is and it now automatically puts your
saves in the cloud so I'm going from my
series X to my Series S then I jump on
my Ally have the game on Steam
continuing my save data data that's the
future of gaming to me and they kind of
pine I don't see other games really
doing this and that really changed the
game cuz now I'm boom on the plane you
know I'm saying boom go back I could go
you know continue my say continue
exactly where I was at love that joint
um yeah I think that the um the G oh I
got corporate Cog moving so when I
played cyberp Punk for the first time I
always did streak kid you know I'm
saying I'll be for the streets you know
what I'm saying running around with
Jackie whatever whatever so this time
I'm like I got to assume my corporate
Cog Persona you know what I'm saying so
I did corpo for the first time on a new
playthrough yo the joint is drastically
different drastically different the
shess then then the boug the way I
entered the game was completely
different I was up at some flying joint
I had the liquor the wine I had like all
it was like I was in a flying limo son
it was crazy yo the corporate Cog join
shout out to the cops they agreed too
they was loving it but um yo dog town is
amazing you know what I'm saying it
looks phenomenal you could tell they
really took their time as far as just
again the graphic Fidelity the way the
game plays all the new changes but to
King's Point 2.0 changes the game the
free update by itself and the last thing
I want to say I think for me why I got
to give them their Redemption Arc this
was the key moment and adct remember
this was cuz y'all went the L we went to
our first packs together this year but
the prior year was my first packs West
and I was out there and they did reach
out I mind you the game was not in a not
that it was in a good space but nobody
was talking about it and I remember they
were like yo you know they're doing like
a screening for um some Edge Runners
thing anime and I was like what's this
but I'm like all right I got time let me
check it out I am not going to front
that that anime was so good at it that
it made me want to play it again and at
that time they had I guess a patch 1.5
or whatever it is that really addressed
core issues that everybody's like yo the
game is playable and then they had some
Edge Runner content in the game when
Edge Runners came out that made me want
to play I don't want to know where where
Adam smash at where I Ain like how you
know what saying like it was one of the
best synergies to kind of get you get
people back into the game and I got to
give them credit man it was really well
done so yeah I do think that um they've
they've they've have the conclusion part
of the Redemption Arc I think the game
is completely playable go check it out I
it's still one of the best looking games
I feel in the generation still to this
to this day and uh yeah we got to
support Stringer Bell man was all about
you know the wire right now what he
doing so what he doing so has there been
recent news with them did they recently
lay off a bunch of people um that's a
good question epic um what team I know
Epic epic did but I think there was
something cuz what I worry about with
them is that guys uh they went through
yeah that was that was epic but this is
this wasn't this wasn't that recent it
was a little little earlier than that
but I could have sworn they let off some
people from the from the the The Witcher
team the the guys that were making the
next it's possible it's been so many
layoffs yeah but that's my worry with
them like they they saw the mistakes
they made with cyber Punk and then they
went right back and when they gave the
roadm they're like yeah we making five
Witcher games and we're making this and
we're making that I'm like whoa whoa
whoa just one at a time take it slowly
you know what I'm saying they give you
this whole road map obviously they're
not going to work on all of them at the
same time but they did say that they
were going to work on certain certain uh
different titles uh simultaneously right
right right so it may be Wonder like
okay what did you come up with in the
ensuing like last two years that makes
you think you can be that flexible you
know so My worry is that please learn
your lesson yes please yes the higher
ups please do not put the devs in this
position anymore let them let them make
the game that they they they set out to
make and give them the time to make it
yeah um and that's it because you don't
want to again people this is the
Redemption Arc now has people in a great
place and you talked about the the
Netflix show yes that also put people in
the state where they wanted more cyber
Punk them yeah it was so well done and
then you then now you give them the
actual game that they wanted three years
ago um and it's like okay cool willing
to to to hear you out now don't mess
that up with absolutely buggy mess or
whatever the next thing is that you're
doing like no absolutely absolutely I
think it was it is a teaching moment for
them as a studio it was a teaching
moment for the industry about rushing
games and putting things out and you're
not ready and like King said the board
and whatever you you got to learn you
risk they risk damaging their pristine
brand reputation and name at that time
so it's so cool to see that they stuck
with it go ahead ad if anything that
shows these other publishing developers
like look like you know they had a solid
product but didn't give it enough time
to fully develop and it's just like
don't don't risk your your your brand
and and you know the the trust of your
consumers and your fans just to make a
quick Buck because you know it's like
that's why I said like it's hard for me
everything in me wants the co sign 100%
going out there redoing the Cyber Punk
stuff but then the other part of me is
like you know even though it hurts the
developers and I hate doing that it's
just
like there's no way you can can make a
statement against what they did with
that without hurting someone that isn't
isn't the crossfire but at the same time
Publishers know that yeah I mean look
it's it's I always feel it's a moral
choice and I feel like you can sit there
and say look I cannot forgive a broken
game they did that I I'm sorry you're
not getting my money you know know what
I I I could respect that I could
understand that and then I can also I
just want to say this last point I can
also understand someone saying look the
decisions of a few shouldn't affect all
the developers who work super hard on
this game and maybe were put in a
position to do something that was
impossible so for me I lean more that
side because they say thousands of
people work on the game but this board
of five this corporate Board of five you
know what I'm saying made a dumb
decision that costed the PO reputation
in the game so I get it it's a personal
decision I feel you but I guess like my
mind is like I've been very vocal
about companies producing less broken
games taking more time and I just I
can't shake it's like they fixed a game
that should have been like this from the
start so is as cool as it is right right
now and I do recommend playing if you
own it I can't REM I can't recommend you
going out and buying it because it's
just like way you cuz at the same time
it's
like then what like right now what's
going on with Battlefield 2042 it's
going on with Halo infinite
like I feel like going out and saying
stuff like that is going to be like okay
you know we can continue doing this
because we could just fix the games
later and it's just like the people
making the money
unfortunately that's not a lot you could
do about it because it's like you can
either support the game because there's
so many people working on it but then
when is the issue ever gonna get fixed
because it's like even though they fixed
it three years later you paid $60 three
years ago to play this game now yeah you
know what I I really do think like the
the big Catalyst for them to really like
turn around on it obviously was not in
great shape but a lot of people on the
PC didn't have a lot of issues with it
it was the console versions obviously it
was that delisting from the PlayStation
yeah that was the reputation hit so that
was
unprecedented yeah I've never seen that
that
really that was Jim Ry was playing that
was that was Jim was not playing with
that that you ain't messing up giving
you no money back B oh yeah they wasn't
do oh yeah cuz PlayStation said yo go to
C yo I forgot forg about that to them
yeah so he would rather take it off his
store and look out for the consumer he
said you know what you none of y'all can
buy this get this out of here now change
the key card on this
game I forgot about that yeah look
that's that I'm sorry somebody speaking
Yeah it's like I said you know I love
the game you know it plays way more
fluidly the the combat's cleaner I'm Ro
rocking around with katana is like it's
like everything in me wants to be like
green light green light but then the
other part of he's like do we really
reward for Stuff fixing that they should
have already real what what about the
Counterpoint if they never fixed it and
just left it broken then obviously we
wouldn't even have this conversation at
all then we would be having this
conversation with The Witcher and not
this game right but my point is there's
no for you I'm just asking a question
about trying to argue with
you is there no what's the word it's not
forgiveness because that's not the word
it's like to Redemption yeah like there
there's no redemption in a way for you
because it's like if they to me a redemp
Phantom Liberty
free that would have been Redemption for
me you know that free update we we we
went above and beyond and we're going to
go ahead and and slide this to you free
of charge because of the condition that
the game was in at launch how many
people bought this on the PS4 and and
Xbox One like and the game was not even
functioning like it it didn't work at
all and and then we got to talk about
the the the sketchy way that they send
out review codes you know you know U you
know trying to silence people just
talking about their experience because
some people got it early it's just like
it's such a great area and then you
could be talking about all this and the
people responsible for all this they're
all gone so no the the 2.0 update is
free and I do remember the um the the
people there was a lot of backlash
because a lot of people that reviewed it
was reviewing the PC version and then it
was like a shock you know kind of
similar to ref for situation right when
the when when the when the console one
came out we like whoa whoo W that kind
of thing so it is what it is but I get
someone said like how Ubisoft did with
the unity DLC giving the first free
instead of charging yeah it's like
sometimes when you mess up bad like it
it's like it's three years too fam like
this a this ain't six months later it's
three years took that long to fix that
that game was busted but so so do you
think do you think like they say they
make the right decision from the jump
and they they cancel those and they but
the game they hold the game till now you
think that's a scenario that would even
happened like they hold game most likely
been but here's the thing what what goes
on behind closed doors and their bottom
line is not my concern what my concern
is in a consumer is getting a
functioning product at launch oh yeah
for sure I'm not saying I'm not saying
that they should have did done what they
did they they they had to do this
because they had to repair their brand
and do is a repair brand I would say
that they did offer you the Cyber Punk
expansion that you did get that that I
mean the Cyber Punk game that they
initially because if they didn't fix
this and put this out there then there
would have been a lot more side eyeing
for The Witcher and it's just like look
like at the end of the day like it's
it's definitely one of those gray areas
because like I said the people that
could literally have been responsible
for the reason the game came out those
higher ups they could all be gone but at
the end of the day sh should CD project
red be punished for the people that left
that's my question that's that's my
question at the same time if we don't
hold the it's it's like when we do the
review things on IGN we don't consider a
an individual writer we consider the
whole entity it don't matter how much
time goes by IGN reviewed that game IGN
gave it that score and it's to me it's
like if we start playing semantics on
who was there and who wasn't there then
at that point you could throw that with
anything it's not about it's not about
who wasn't there it's about the people
who are power to make decisions though
like we can't blame people who have no
power what their bosses are telling them
what to do and if they're not in
agreement with it we're going to blame
them too I can't that part no one's
blaming
them but I'm saying no one's blaming
them now now but at the time the whole
studio got dragged every single person
was CD project red and how could you do
this CD project
red at the same time when you look at if
are we supposed to let the higher ups
off them no I'm not saying let anybody
I'm just saying that there is a
distinction between the people who make
the decisions and the people who make
the game that's all I'm saying that
there there is a path to hey I'm not
going to punish the people who are
making the games if the bosses were not
making the right calls but once again
you not punishing them means that the
other side gets off scof fre no I didn't
I didn't I didn't pick up the joint I
stopped I was like I'm I'm good until
y'all get it together that's exactly
what I said that's what king said I was
like this is not acceptable again it's a
personal decision right some people said
NOP I'm good I'm playing it I like it PC
was fine me I'm like that wasn't
acceptable so I'm good when y'all decide
to come back around and get it together
and look like we're finally here now
then I'm like all right I'll go check
y'all out but I I I I think you can vote
with your wallet and and not support the
behavior to your point right cuz you're
like yo don't support the behavior and I
think that's a okay decision to make
yeah everybody
good okay sry
like they could so something like this
we're clearly not gonna agree on so
I'm I'm not disagreeing with you no no
not that you're saying I'm just saying
that you know some companies get a
chance to have a pathway to Redemption
if the board is forcing them they have
no control over
that so so so uh adct in so in your
scenario like so that does your feelings
towards this translate to the next
Witcher like I'm not messing with you
here's the thing I just don't like the
way they released the game at the end of
the day I just don't like it and you
know me coming out there and saying like
you have to earn that trust back now I
do like I said they had to release this
to earn that trust back if they didn't
have released this then I would be more
and and I don't even care about The
Witcher anyway so most likely I won't be
playing that but it it's just I just
don't like the practice I don't like you
know suits going out there pushing games
out there to an audience that they know
is broken using you know very shady
reviewing tactics to make sure that
people get the the copies that work you
know uh go it's just I don't I don't
like it and you know and you and you
support it by not picking it up
right yeah you didn't you didn't rock
with it right you still your Square I'm
not talking about that I'm talk that's
not the debate the debate isn't then the
debate is should you buy now even when
they did that back then right and your
point is you're not rewarding anything
because even if it's a Redemption AR
that's where you at you're like I don't
like what happened from the beginning
I'm good you it's in a good place it's
too late that's where you at like I'm
not disagreeing with you like you
thinking I'm debating you I'm just
saying I'm just trying to understand
your point you're like even if the
developer they fix it and they do
whatever it doesn't matter because the
way y'all launched it the way yall did
that was shady and I'm good so and I
right and s's follow-up question to you
is because of that that makes you
question everything else moving forward
like if the new Witcher come out you
like yo I don't know because this what I
did with cyberp Punk is that correct it
puts me in the position where I'm
like with their games until I get a game
or two in it's not a day one it's just
wait and see like it's no pre-order kind
of thing it's like you you you you
served me a game barely function you
don't get the right to demand my money
the next time going around that's fair
and and I totally that's why I said
always I always said this is a personal
decision right and when someone does
something like you you good like ain't
nothing wrong with that that's totally
fine by me so that's I said we ain't
disagreeing I'm just listening to your
point anyway we are are we good
everybody got the their bars off M all
right cool let's get the uh super chats
please